[Musique]
bien donc j'ai introduit jean marc
jancovici
alors c'est jean marc est un être
bizarre mais très intéressant parce que
il fait partie de ces gens qui ont une
vision très globale comme vous allez le
voir est très intéressante sur une
surprenante d'aspe énergétique et
économique de nos sociétés et il fait ce
que personnellement moi j'aime bien et
que j'essaye de faire comme vous l'avez
vu dans la façon dont je présente les
problématiques que soit le
photovoltaïque la dernière fois où le
l'habitat aujourd'hui c'est à dire que
il raisonne à la fois sur des bases
scientifiques solides et pas du bla bla
bla et ils antilles où il essaye d'en
tirer des conclusions qui sont des
conclusions qui vont jusqu'à des
conclusions de la société qui ont trait
à dans le cas présent évidemment
l'énergie et des aspects économiques
voilà donc il a la une société qui aide
les entreprises à calculer le bilan
carbone etc et même d'autres choses mais
il a aussi un site pour ceux qui ne le
connaissent pas absolument magnifique
sur l'énergie que l'on peut consulter
sur internet qui est une mine d'idées
une mine d'informations et que je vous
recommande au plus long au plus haut
plus haut point voilà donc on va le
laisser comme vous avez vu il a par
contre un tout petit peu de problèmes de
2,2 voilà il fait du flux tendu comédie
voilà donc la conférence est prête il
conférence i o 6 voilà a tout de suite
merci merci beaucoup à didier de m'avoir
conviés à partager ce moment avec lui
c'est toujours un honneur de se
retrouver dans cette enceinte
au lieu de la science et qui me rappelle
un vieux souvenir puisqu'il se trouve
que j'ai fait mes premières armes 200
mètres au dessus il y a malheureusement
un grand nombre d'années ce que je vais
vous montrer maintenant c'est un peu un
pot pourri de réflexion quantifier
autour de la autour de la question de
l'énergie du changement climatique et du
bâtiment
cet engin essaie de se mettre d'accord
avec le vidéoprojecteur ce que je vais
vous ce que je vais vous faire donc
c'est à la fois quelques réflexion
d'ensemble autour de la du défi qui se
présente à nous en ce qui concerne la
question du changement climatique
je parlerai très peu d'énergie ce matin
et je vous parlerai également d'un
certain nombre
j'ai gagné donc il a planté
et je vous parlerai également d'un
certain nombre de
de choses concernant le bâtiment en
france et en europe
celle que je vous montrerai la situation
de départ en en ce qui concerne le
bâtiment et didier vous a fait rêver
avec le bâtiment du futur
moi je vais vous faire trembler avec le
bâtiment du passé ça va plutôt être ça
bon ben voila je suis désolé il faut que
cet engin phyllis de retrouver ses
esprits
voilà donc didier je leur dis vous a
fait rêver avec des bâtiments du futur
moi je vais vous parler de là où vous
habitez vraiment c'est à dire non pas
chez nanouk l'esquimau mais dans des
choses qui ressemblent plus à ça wassa
ou à sa ou et ça soit dit en passant une
réflexion liminaire tout de suite quand
on parle bâtiment et notamment quand on
parle de bâtiments à des csp + auquel
appartiennent les décideurs et qu'on
leur explique qu'il va falloir commencer
à toucher aux bâtiments existants comme
tous ces braves gens habitent dans les
trucs haussmannien où il n'est pas
question de changer un appui de fenêtre
sans que ça dégrade la façade
il vous explique tout sont au mieux on
ne peut rien faire à cause du caractère
architectural et c'est moi je trouve que
j'habite en banlieue à côté d'une ville
nouvelle qui a été construite dans les
années 60 70 et je vous assure que les
tours qui ont été construites c'est
caractère architectural vraiment pas le
sujet donc il faut se sortir quand on
est parisien et en particulier vieux et
riches ce qui doit être le cas d'un
certain nombre de gens dans cette salle
de l'idée qu'il ya que deux
l'haussmannien dans le monde et que on
ne peut strictement rien faire parce que
sinon on se prend les bâtiments de
france et tout le reste sur la figure je
vais donc comme je voulais dire partir
mois d'un tout petit truc qui s'appelle
l'accord de paris que nous avons célébré
en grande pompe il y a maintenant un peu
plus d'un an en disant victoire la
planète et sauver puisqu'on a décidé
tous ensemble de se mettre d'accord pour
sauver la planète
je vais donc faire appel à une autre
science soit dit en passant a enseigné
dans cette enceinte
certains d'entre vous sont peut être
venu écouter edouard bard
et je vous montre là un graphique qui
est issu du dernier rapport du giec
alors le giec comme vous le savez
peut-être c'est une instance onusienne
qui a été créée en 1988 et qui est une
espèce d' agences de vulgarisation de la
littérature scientifique existante
c'est un guichet unique d'accès à la
littérature scientifique existante sur
la question de l'influencé de l'homme
sur le climat
je ne pense pas qu'ils aient beaucoup de
gens dans cette salle qui est lui un
rapport complet du giec puisque même le
premier faisait déjà quelques centaines
de pages
le dernier en fait 6000 donc je pense
que vous n'avez pas des insomnies
suffisant dans cette salle pour vous
attaquer à ce genre de trucs il ya quand
même de temps en temps des choses
intéressantes qui s'y promènent alors là
voilà un graphique ce graphique il dit
quelque chose d'extrêmement simple il
vous quantifie sur toute une série de
courbes qui ont au premier
approximations décide une droite
la réponse du système climatique en ce
qui concerne son élévation de
température globale en fonction de la
quantité de co2 que nous mettrons dans
l'atmosphère entre le début de l'ère
industrielle 2100 donc c'est assez
simple je prends la quantité totale de
co2 que les hommes mettent dans
l'atmosphère entre 1870 et 2100 dont une
partie évidemment a déjà eu des mises et
ça me donne la réponse du système
climatique en ce qui concerne
l'élévation de température entre 1863
850 en l'occurrence et 2100 alors
applications numériques
je prends les émissions que les hommes
et les femmes pardon de ne pas les
oublier ont mis dans l'atmosphère entre
1870 et 2015 peu près de 1000 milliards
de tonnes de co2 dont vous avez la
répartition sur la droite et vous voyez
que historiquement c'est le charbon et
la déforestation qui arrive en tête pas
le pétrole et je mets ça je projet de ça
sur ma droite et la droite étant une
direction j'ai appris à l'école
eh bien je n'ai qu'une seule réponse
possible en ce qui concerne l'élévation
de température du système climatique
entre maintenant et 2100 qui est un
degré quelque chose dit autrement ce
qu'on a déjà mis dans l'atmosphère ce
qu'on a déjà mis dans l'atmosphère
garantie que en 2100 nous aurons un
virgule quelque chose degrés
d'élévation de la moyenne planétaire par
rapport à 1850
alors je vais vous le dire d'une autre
manière les 1,5 degré qui constitue
l'objectif ultime de l'accord de paris
ça vaut autant que les promesses
électorales que vous avez eu depuis
quelques mois c'est à dire rien ça ne
vaut rien pas un clou la physique vous
dit déjà que c'est beau c'est terminé
les 1,5 degré fallait six enfants
descendent occupé avant c'est fini c'est
impossible de les avoir
les deux degrés ça reste encore possible
et à ce moment vous fait le raisonnement
à l'envers vous dit bah voila je veux
cap et l'élévation globale des
températures du système à deux degrés et
bien la physique me dis que je ne dois
pas mettre plus de 3000 milliards de
tonnes de co2 dans l'atmosphère entre
1870 et 2100 dont 2000 ont déjà été
émises
donc si vous touchez un héritage de 1000
euros et vous en avait déjà dépensé 700
on va vous savez faire la différence
comme moi il en reste trois cents voilà
c'est exactement pareil on a un budget
global de 3000 on en a déjà émis deux
villes dont il en reste 1000 alors j'ai
tout de suite être désagréable ça veut
dire que sur le siècle qui vient vos
enfants et petits enfants
un bruit de cheveux blancs dans cette
salle ils ont le droit d'émettre
collectivement la moitié de ce que vous
et vos parents avez émis dans le cadre
d'une humanité qui est en moyenne sur le
siècle trois fois plus nombreuses c'est
ça le cahier des charges du autrement
vos enfants et petits enfants vous leur
donner le droit d'émettre en moyenne le
sixième de ce que vous vous avez aimé
sachant que l'énergie c'est pas dans
cette enceinte que je vais vous
apprendre grand chose c'est ce qui
quantifie le changement d'état d'un
système dit autrement c'est ce qui
permet d'agir sur le monde
ça veut dire que nos enfants et petits
enfants pour la partie qui vient de
l'énergie fossile
nous leur donnons le droit de
transformer six fois moins
l'environnement par personne que nous et
nos parents c'est ça que ça veut dire
et ce qui veut dire soit dit en passant
aussi au premier ordre que voulant
donner droit à six fois moins de pib par
personne donc les deux degrés
c'est six fois moins de pib par personne
en première approximation sauf
efficacité énergétique mais en fait j'ai
pas le temps de vous montrer les courbes
ce matin mais ça va pas du tout je vous
le dis encore autres vendent au degré
c'est s'est férocement récessif c'est
bien la raison pour laquelle ça fait 25
ans 1992 je sais ça 25 ans pour
paraphraser cet excellent brice lalonde
ça fait 25 ans qu'on se réunit pour
résoudre le problème est que le problème
n'est pas résolu à cause de ça vous
allez me dire tout ça est horrible macro
et l'open réunis nous promettent de la
croissance donc on s'en fout des
émissions donc on aura deux d'adressés
web
alors je vais vous montrer non pas sur
deux degrés mais sur le passé un ordre
de grandeur pour ceux d'entre vous qui
ne connaissent pas encore il faut
vraiment garder en tête parce qu'il est
absolument cardinal dans cette affaire
qui est très bien admettons que je me
contrefous tu du problème parce que y
attaquer ces quand même trop désagréable
est-ce que je peux avoir quelque chose
d'un peu tangible qui parle un peu
indécent ce qui me permet de comprendre
de quoi je parle en termes de
conséquences
alors pour ça je vais faire appel à deux
cartes très simple la première vous
décrit les écosystèmes climax hic c'est
à dire ceux qui sont là si on leur fout
la paix et qu'on les supprime pas pour
faire des champs notre dame de paris
des bâtiments du futur ou des bâtiments
du passé des routes ou toutes autres
installations humaines
donc voilà à quoi ressemble les
écosystèmes qui aujourd'hui s'installe
spontanément en europe
si on les laisse tranquilles nous avait
essentiellement des forêts ça veut dire
que le système climatique sur l'europe
est un système qui n'est ni trop chaud
il n'est pas il n'est pas en dehors des
plages de température qui permettent la
croissance des végétaux mais il n'est
pas non plus en dehors des plages de
précipitations qui permettent la
croissance des gros végétaux donc il
pleut assez en particulier vous avez ici
l'europe il y a vingt mille ans donc la
vraie milan on est au coeur de la
dernière ère glaciaire il fait
raisonnablement froid et nos ancêtres de
l'époque
pour suivre les derniers mammouth en
espérant bien on attrape et un allons
vous voyez que l'europe il ya vingt
mille ans ne ressemble pas vraiment à
l'europe d'aujourd'hui
la première chose qui la distingue de
manière absolument fondamental c'est que
c'est compliqué d'aller faire erasmus en
suède ou au danemark parce que les
suédois et les danois sont sous la glace
vous avez une énorme calotte glaciaire
de quelques kilomètres d'épaisseur qui
recouvre toute la scandinavie le nord de
l'allemagne le danemark soit dit en
passant les écossais qui cesse d'être
une menace au rugby ils sont plus là et
vous avez sa grande soeur qui est posée
sur le canada laurentides donc vous avez
quelque chose d'assez différent
de ce point de vue cette glace s'est
constitué d'eau et cette eau il a bien
fallu la prendre quelque part c'est pas
dans l'atmosphère que vous avez des
réserves d'eau suffisante pour
constituer les têtes volume de glace
c'est le seul endroit où vous avez pu la
prendre cette hausse est dans la mer or
la mère est une grande baignoire le fond
de la baignoire n'a pas varié donc si
vous avez pris énormément d'eau pour
constituer cette calotte
le niveau de l'eau a baissé et il n'a
pas baissé un peu il a baissé de 120
mètres dont pour ceux d'entre vous qui
aime aller batifoler dans la manche il
ya plus de manches
et pour ceux d'entre vous qui avaient
des économies à planquer dans les anglo
normandes ya plus d'angle normande
vous avez une petite colline à la place
et les bonnes années on peut aller
mettre la pâtée aux irlandais à pied sec
pas besoin de paume et ses économies
dans eurotunnel pour faire ce genre de
choses vous constaté également que les
écosystèmes installés sont très très
différent de ce que nous avons
aujourd'hui vous avez en gros des
écosystèmes qui ressemble à ce que nous
avons aujourd'hui au nord de la sibérie
s'est pas exactement pareil que ce que
nous avons aujourd'hui et dans cet
univers là on peut nourrir des animaux
en bout de chaîne alimentaire comme les
hommes mais un peu moins nombreux que ce
que nous sommes aujourd'hui puisque à
cette époque là la population française
est de l'ordre de la population d'un
arrondissement parisien
cent mille bon diable donc tout ce que
l'écosystème france à cette époque là
peut nourrir comme aux hommes c'est cent
mille individus quand la terre est passé
de l'état de gauche à l'état de droite
évidemment la température moyenne a
augmenté réchauffer et bien l'élévation
de température moyenne dont on parle
son ordre de grandeur ces cinq degrés
sont d'ordre de grandeur c'est 5 degrés
cette élévation de température elle a
mis quelques milliers d'années à se
produire de l'ordre de 5000 canton 5 et
des mines donc là vous avez le résultat
de la seule expérience grandeur nature
de transition climatique rapide à
l'échelle géologique rapide à l'échelle
géologique que notre espèce est connu
ces cinq degrés en cinq mille ans pour
la faire simple donc un degré par
millénaire 012 réparé siècle 0,1 degré
par siècle
je vous signale qu'en ce moment on est
dans certaines régions du monde sur un
rythme d'évolution de la température qui
est donc 0,1 degré 0.05 donc juste la
moitié par année paradis déjà
aujourd'hui dans certaines régions du
alors évidemment si le réchauffement
climatique n'était pas un réchauffement
mais un refroidissement c'est à dire que
si ce qu'on faisait en ce moment on
conduisait à refroidir la température
planétaire de 5 degrés en un siècle
là je peux déjà vous donner la facture
ça fait quelques milliards de morts
vous rendez toutes les moyennes
latitudes un que les moyennes latitudes
non cultivables l'ordre de grandeur
ces quelques milliards de morts cette
expérience de réchauffement de quelques
degrés en un siècle il ya là j'avais
fait donc le l'idéal ça serait disposé
dans le système solaire de 427 planète
terre qui aurait donc ce que didier vous
a montré tout à l'heure sur
l'instrumentation moi je suis comme lui
je suis traite de genia d'abord faux
instrumenté regarder confrontent et
c'est bon et si on avait 427 planète
terre permettant d'avoir vu ce que
devenait une humanité de quelques
milliards d'individus mettant des gaz à
effet de serre dans l'atmosphère puis on
pourrait aller leurs résultats avec des
gens qui ont commencé ça il ya ainsi
acquis à deux siècles ya trois siècles
et quatre siècles qui ont mis un peu
quand on lit beaucoup et c est bien on
aura une idée du risque au concours et
même dans ce cas de figure soit dit en
passant c'est pas sûr qu'on ferait ce
qu'il faut il ya des tas de trucs qui
nous font courir des risques le tabac la
drogue conduire en voiture etc
pour autant il est temps qu'ils s'en
foutent donc ça veut pas dire pour
autant qu'on aurait fait ce qu'il faut
un enfant au moins on aurait une idée du
risque
là on s est un grand saut dans l'inconnu
si on fait ça ma conviction
donc je vais vous le dire tout de suite
pour qu'on passe à la suite ma
conviction c'est que ce genre de
transition
à cette vitesse c'est la guerre partout
en première approximation donc vous
aurez un effondrement de l' échelle
spatiale de l'organisation des sociétés
humaines
c'est aujourd'hui on sait faire des
sociétés humaines organisé à l'échelle
d'un pays voire à l'échelle du monde
ça s'effondrera est du reste les
mouvements populistes aujourd'hui en
sont les prémices vous aurez un
effondrement de l'espérance de vie la
taille de la population mais dans des
proportions que je suis un foutu de
quantifier donc je sais pas vous dire si
l'espérance de vie diminuera de 5 ans 10
ans sera divisé par deux ou par trois
j'en ai aucune idée
je vous rappelle quand même que
l'espérance de vie en moyenne sur la
planète
il ya deux siècles c'était au loup
alentours de 25 ans l'espérance de vie à
la naissance
donc je ne sépare a donc comme dit
l'autre camp je ne sais pas c'est
compris entre 0 et 100 % mais il est
évident que on n'est pas en train de
parler d'un truc anecdotique on est en
train de parler de quelque chose qui a
le potentiel pour dynamiter la totalité
de ce qu'on considère aujourd'hui être
les acquis éternelle d'une société
stable et opulente
ça a le potentiel pour dynamiter ce à
dire bon très bien j'ai compris on
s'agite
alors si on s'agite qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire je le redis que
on n'a plus le droit qu'à 1000 milliards
de tonnes équivalent co2 enfin milliards
de tonnes par an de co2 à émettre d'ici
à la fin du siècle
alors une fois que j'ai en termes
mathématiques ça veut dire que je
prescris l'intégrale de mes émissions
et maintenant je vais essayer de voir à
quoi ressemble la courbe de mes
émissions
bien évidemment si j'ai un budget tout
ce qui est raisonnement en année est une
supercherie c'est à dire que si on vous
dit vous avez encore le droit d'émettre
temps ça ne correspond à rien de dire je
vais émettre ce que j'ai mais
aujourd'hui tous les ans à peu près la
même chose
et puis dès que j'ai épuisé mon budget
je passe à 0 ça c'est l'hypothèse chute
de comètes chute de météorite guerre
thermonucléaire d'un niveau suffisant
etc
mais sinon c'est pas comme ça que ça va
se passer c'est vous passez par un
maximum et vous diminuées
c'est comme pour la démographie alors le
les divers scénarios que vous avez ici
sont des scénarios qui vous quantifie
l'élévation de température que vous
obtenez en 2100 donc celui dont vous
avez vos 5 degrés c et si vous voulez
vous limiter à deux degrés mais vous
voyez le scénario qui vous intéresse il
est en bas là et ce scénario là il dit
que d'ici à 2050 donc d'ici à ce que vos
enfants et votre âge il faut avoir des
visées les émissions planétaires par
trois donc les générations futures ça
devient hyper concret c'est aux enfants
voilà donc vous les voyez tous les jours
en rentrant chez vous pour ceux qui
habitent encore avec eux et à chaque
fois que vous les avez au téléphone
voilà c'est ça les générations futures
si c'est pas des espèces de machin
intemporel mal définis qui arriveront
dans trois siècles et demi non non non
non les générations futures c'est tous
les gens dans cette salle comme moins de
65 ans c'est très très concret c'est
sain l'ordre de grandeur alors vous
allez me dire c'est pas grave à paris on
s'est mis d'accord sur le fait que en
algérie alors j'ai fait un petit
exercice que les anglo-saxons appellent
de fact checking en ce qui concerne
l'accord de paris c'est à dire que au
moment de l'accord de paris on s'est mis
d'accord sur un objectif qui soit dit en
passant était déjà dans l'accord de
copenhague l'accord de copenhague disait
déjà deux degrés on limite l'élévation
de température planétaire à 2 degrés
sauf que comme cet accord il n'avait pas
été obtenu par la voie classique
onusienne dans lequel les gens se
mettent d'accord sur 45
explosif 45 sur 60 pages de textes et
chaque virgule mais que c'était un truc
en 12 boulet de poynt qui avait été
écrit pendant une nuit entre chefs
d'état les ong engueuler comme des
putois en disant race est pas
démocratique et c'est donc ce truc là
vaut pas un clou
donc je j'affirme que les ong ont fait
perdre six ans au monde en présentant
comme un échec
ce qui était un immense succès c'est à
dire d'avoir déjà commencé à se mettre
d'accord sur les deux degrés on a perdu
6 ans à cause de ça à cause d'elle à
cause d'elle j'insiste donc ici vous
avez quelque chose de très simple c'est
la somme des émissions auxquelles les
pays se sont engagés à paris parce qu'à
paris en gros on a inventé un système
pas idiot sur le fond qui était chaque
pays arrive en disant qu'il est prêt à
faire donc on se donne pas un objectif
comme à kyoto en disant on va répartir
la réduction des émissions machin toi tu
fais 1% -3 d'un on a fait l'un vers son
audience mais d'accord sur un objectif
global et qui chacun arrive avec ce
qu'il est prêt à faire et puis on essaye
de discuter pour que le total de ce
qu'on aimait correspondent avec
l'objectif global
sauf qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas
vous avez vu sur ce graphique que si on
veut les 2 degrés il faut pas commencer
la réduction dans cinq ans ou dans dix
ans il faut la commencer demain matin
pour la commencer demain matin tout de
suite là maintenant demain matin or à
paris si vous faites la somme des
engagements des pays
tout ce que vous obtenez c'est que les
émissions augmentent pour passer en gros
de 50 à 60 milliards de tonnes par an
l'espace de dix ans donc ça prend pas
vraiment le chemin d'une économie ainsi
vous allez voir votre banquier et que
votre banquier vous dis aux dépenses
sont excessives par rapport à vos
revenus et que vous lui dites pas de
problème j'ai bien compris le message
mais sur les dix années qui viennent de
garde les revenus et j'augmente mes
dépenses pense qu'il va vous regarder en
vous disant je suis pas sûr qu'il ait
vraiment compris ce que vient de lui
dire mais il sait exactement pareil à
paris
c'est à dire qu'on n'est pas sûr on est
vraiment bien compris ce qu'on nous a
dit ce que vous avez également en bleu
et en rouge c'est le rythme de
diminution qui doit être celui des
émissions de la planète alors cédé
diminution exponentielle en cx % par an
ce n'est pas linéaire
selon l'année à laquelle on se met à
l'ouvragé
donc vous voyez que si on attend encore
trois ans
il faut derrière qu'on baisse de 5% par
an les émissions planétaires et si on
attend encore dix ans il faut qu on les
baisse de 10%
je me suis amusé si l'on peut dire à
regarder quel avait été le rythme annuel
de croissance des émissions de co2 sur
le siècle passé
je veux dire comme ça je vais avoir une
petite idée est ce que 5% c'est loin ou
pas loin de ce qu'on sait faire
alors voilà le rythme annuel de
variation des émissions de co2 année
après année j'ai pris des séries qui
sont alors c'est pas le même moteur se
passe musulmans face à un autre voisin
donc je regarde la consommation
d'énergie année après année je prends un
facteur d'émission qui est toujours le
même parce que pour pas m'emmerder la
vie même si c'est un et je regarde de
combien varie les émissions année après
année eh bien vous voyez que vous avez
deux points et deux seulement sur ce
graphique ou le rythme annuel de baisse
des émissions a été de 5%
2 le plus fort de la crise de 29 et
l'anéantissement du japon de l'allemagne
voilà deux donc faire ça de manière
volontaire c'est pas quelque chose qui
est marginale à côté d'un programme de
civilisation qui reste croissance
forever et je touche ni aux systèmes de
retraite liées aux 35 heures ne sais pas
quoi
c'est au coeur d'un programme de
civilisation où ça marche pas et si
c'est pas au coeur d'un pas ici c'est au
coeur d'un programme de civilisation il
ya nécessairement des contreparties
assez désagréable pour nous qui sortons
de deux siècles de croissance
ininterrompue qui s'appelle la
contraction du pouvoir d'achat et tout
un tas d'autres trucs qui aujourd'hui
sont considérés comme absolument
inconcevable
alors sauf que j'ai une très bonne
nouvelle pour vous je crois que c'est le
chatelier 1 qui a dit que les systèmes
et pas se trouver un équilibre
aujourd'hui nous avons mis le système
hors d'équilibré donc il se régulera de
toute façon donc la question n'est pas
de savoir si on veut que le système
change ou pas la question est de savoir
si on veut qu'ils changent avec nous ou
sans nous et en général quand les
systèmes change sans nous il ya que deux
grands modes de régulation dans le monde
enfin ou trois plus exactement
l'oppression politique la famine la
maladie la guerre étant une forme
particulière de pression politique c'est
les 3 grands modes de régulation y en a
pas d'autre donc si on dit je veux pas
c'est qu'on est d'accord pour la guerre
la famine et la maladie
c'est assez simple c'est très simple les
émissions en question et je vais faire
le lien avec le bâtiment évidemment du
yen vous avez ici un camembert et pour
éviter que vous vous endormirez avant le
déjeuner je vous ai pas mis la légende
tout de suite qui vous donne la
répartition des émissions mondiales en
pourcentage donc c'est quels sont les
grands postes d'émission souvent quand
on donne les émissions mondiales on les
donne par gaz on les donne par nrj etc
là je vous ai fait une cuisine
personnelle dans laquelle je les
présente par type d'activité slash
énergie c'est c1 c'est un 20% des
émissions planétaires sont le fait des
centrales à charbon
donc les seules centrales à charbon dans
le monde ces 20% des émissions
planétaires
soit dit en passant vous avez
aujourd'hui 2000 gigawatts de puissance
installée de centrales à charbon dans le
monde
nous on s'excite comme des fous sur de
60 gigawatts de nucléaire 2000 gigawatts
de centrales à charbon dans le monde
il faut tout l'est m à la ferraille dans
les trente cinq ans qui viennent je dis
bien tout si on veut avoir une chance
d'obtenir les 2 degrés je peux vous dire
que pas une seconde
compte tenu des différences de capitaux
à investir entre le nucléaire et éolien
ou pv par une seconde
vous pouvez y arriver avec juste de
l'éolien et du pv par une seconde
donc les gens qui sont contre le
nucléaire sont pour le maintien des
centrales à charbon en plus grande
quantité en plus nucléaire pour le
maintien des centrales à charbon en plus
grande quantité
c'est aussi con que ça 7% sont le fait
des centrales à gaz et à fuel
vous verrez un peu plus tard en ordre de
grandeur la production électrique au
fuel aujourd'hui n'est pas très éloigné
de ce qu'elle était il ya 30 ans
évidemment par relatifs à baisser en
ordre de grandeur en valeur absolue
c'est pas très différent à là on
commence à taper dans le domaine de
didier 5% des émissions planétaires
c'est les cimenteries la plus grosse
société émettrice au monde sauf erreur
de ma part c'est lafarge holcim
là dedans vous avez les deux tiers qui
viennent n'ont pas de l'utilisation de
l'énergie mais du fait que faire du
ciment c'est pas très loin de faire de
la chaux vive donc vous prenez du
calcaire carbonate de calcium caco3 et
vous coupez la molécule en deux ans
chauffeur très fort entre seao qui
mélangés à d'autres poudre de
perlimpinpin va vous donner le plein
caire plus ciment et co2 qui part dans
l'air donc deux tiers de la fabrication
du ciment
enfin deux tiers des émissions qui
viennent de la fabrication du ciment
c'est la réaction elle même c'est de la
chimie
c'est le fait d'avoir cassé la molécule
en deux donc il suffit pas de changer
d'énergie pour supprimer sa sas et
irréductible temps vous faites du
clinquet ranshofen très fort du calcium
un tiers c'est l'utilisation de
l'énergie souvent du charbon ont
quelquefois du gaz 12% c'est le reste de
l'industrie dans lequel vous avez
l'aciérie qui représente encore aussi en
ordre de grandeur 5 % des émissions
mondiales
vous avez en gros un millier un peu plus
d'un milliard de tonnes d'acier
fabriqués par an dans le monde pour
faire une tonne d'acier faut faire en
gros deux tonnes de co2 en or de
vendeurs vous avez 2 milliards sur 50
milliards
oui on n'est pas très loin du 5% la
fabrication des autres matériaux de base
vous fait encore un énorme paquet en
gros dans les émissions globales de
l'industrie c'est fabriquer le ciment
les métaux notamment l'acier et les
produits chimiques de base qui vous
occasionne 80% des émissions directes
je dis bien direct par pas de la
consommation électrique transformée
l'acier en boulons 12 s'est
considérablement moins émissifs que le
simple fait de fabriquer l'acier dont
vous avez un vrai sujet dans cette
histoire qui est de fabriquer moins de
matériaux donc je ne sais pas
pour taquiner un peu si effectivement la
population passera à 9 milliards ou pas
à 9 milliards parce que je ne sais pas
s'il y aura des régulations involontaire
massive qui s'appliqueront ou pas dans
les trente cinq ans qui viennent
je sais qu'elles finiront par
s'appliquer c'est tout ce que je sais
le jeu ne sait pas si ces gens là ils
vivront dans des bidonvilles en allant
squatter chez les copains qui sont déjà
là ou en construisant des nouveaux
bâtiments
s'ils viennent en ville je ne sais pas
non plus par contre ce que je sais c'est
que aujourd'hui l'essentiel de la
construction dans les villes modernes
c'est acier acier béton
c'est ça l'essentiel c'est pas
compatible avec la solution au problème
les chaudières des bâtiments en direct
donc les émissions qui prennent place
directement dans les bâtiments ça n'est
que 6 % des émissions mondiales
alors vous allez dire c'est pour cent
c'est quand même beaucoup si on va
diviser par trois n'ont pas laissé
inchangé et puis surtout vous allez voir
que c'est très dépendant de la
géographie à l'évidence quand vous êtes
à singapour ou quand vous êtes au
sénégal chauffer des bâtiments s'est pas
vraiment d'autres sujets dont vous
n'allez pas avoir des missions direct
vous allez avoir des émissions
indirectes liées à la production
électrique qui permet d'alimenter l'air
conditionné par contre vous n'avez pas
d'émissions directes
quand vous êtes en suède où quand vous
êtes en finlande où quand vous êtes en
lettonie fait un peu plus froid l'hiver
et à ce moment vous avez évidemment des
émissions dues au chauffage pour autant
que vous utilisiez des combustibles
fossiles dans le chauffage 15% des
émissions planétaires sont dues au
transport dans lesquelles les voitures
c'est à peu près 6 % les camions 4 et
les bateaux et les avions de chacun
alors regardez là quelque chose de très
intéressant à l'échelle du monde dans
son ensemble
les voitures c'est pas un problème plus
important que les cimenteries par - mais
pas plus donc dire il va falloir faire
avec moins de voitures oui mais le
problème des émissions est très très
loin de se réduire à la seule question
des voitures très loin de se réduire
alors j'ai pas le temps ce matin
j'aurais pu sinon vous montrer que de
toute façon en europe
la décrue pétrolière est amorcée c'est à
dire que pour des raisons géologiques
l'approvisionnement pétrolier de
l'europe est déjà en contraction et donc
la quantité de carburant consommé par
les automobilistes et les chauffeurs
routiers et de toute façon en train de
se réduire avec ou sans votre aide
c'est de toute façon afin de laisser 20%
2 des émissions planétaires sont liées à
des processus d'origine agricole dans
les gaz à effet de serre vous avez
certes le co2 mais je vous renvoie aux
excellents cours d'ici vous avez
également d'autres gaz notamment le
méthane et le protoxyde d'azoté dont les
origines sont essentiellement agricole
le méthane vient des processus de
fermentation anaérobie que vous avez
dans l'appareil digestif des ruminants
il vient également de la fermentation
des déjections donc toutes les crottes
des animaux d'élevage
il vient de la fermentation à nouveau à
nairobi dans les rizières donc là vous
avez un procédé très low tech mais assez
efficace pour diminuer les émissions de
méthane des rizières celi mettre des
cartes ou des canards donc c'est pas
high tech du tout mais c'est très
efficace banque de développement devrait
financer ce genre de trucs et voilà donc
vous avez des les émissions de protoxyde
pardon sont liés à l'épandage des
engrais azotés dans les champs à ce
moment vous avez une partie des nitrates
qui sont réduits en protoxyde d azote
d'asie dans qui est émis par les chants
la déforestation qui est un processus
avant de l'agriculture processus qui
prend place en général en réponse à
l'accroissement démographique et donc à
la nécessité de convertir de surface de
forêt en surface cultivée c'est ce qui
s'est passé en europe maximum de la
surface déforester en 1850
c'est ce qui s'est passé aux états unis
et c'est ce qui est en train de se
passer en ce moment dans les pays dits
émergents c'est 10 % des émissions ce
qui veut dire que la fonction
alimentaire au sens large
si je mets boutabout la déforestation il
ya un peu de bois de feu en afrique mais
globalement c'est des cultures et les
émissions agricoles c'est un tiers des
émissions mondiales
un tiers ça fait beaucoup et enfin 10%
vous avez des bricoles diverses la
gestion des déchets
le traitement des eaux etc donc ça c'est
le panorama mondial alors en europe où
on est au moyen de l'attitude ça va être
un peu différent parce que effectivement
on se chauffe
alors vous voyez par exemple que les
émissions dues au chauffage en europe
c'est pas si c'est presse pour cent je
parle bien des émissions directes et un
repas des émissions indirectes liées à
l'utilisation de l'électricité
l'industrie c'est 18 alors que dans mon
schéma précédent j'étais à 17
oui je vous prie loin les centrales
électriques ses 26 vous voyez que pardon
vous voyez que en moyenne mondiale ces
28 pas très différent et par contre
l'agriculture s'est significativement
moins 12%
mais en fait la raison c'est parce que
le reste est significativement plus
élevés c'est c'est pas parce qu'on mange
moins c'est parce que on a plus
d'industrie et de centrales électriques
que en moyenne mondiale dans les pays
africains vous avez surtout des
émissions agricoles beaucoup moins
d'émissions industrielles et les
transports sont un peu plus élevés
également en part relative
alors je vous dis là encore une fois
c'est les émissions directes des
bâtiments sauf que vous avez aussi un
paquet de ce truc là didier vous a
montré tout à l'heure je vous montrerai
que les bâtiments consomment une
fraction significative de l'énergie
qu'on consomme dans les pays occidentaux
et en particulier y consomme de
l'électricité à dire l'électricité en
france les pas de co2 encore que
peut-être qu'une personne sur deux va me
dire linverse car je vous donne une
information vous ne connaissez peut-être
pas quand vous demandez aux français
dans leur ensemble
est ce qu'à votre avis les centrales
nucléaires contribuer de manière
significative aux émissions gaz à effet
de serre et bien vous en avait un sur
deux qui vous dit oui
donc ça étonne peut être des gens dans
cette salle mais le fait brut c'est que
un sur deux le pense du coup c'est très
logique qu'on dise que dans le cadre de
la transition énergétique qui vise à
répondre notamment aux questions du
changement climatique faux pc nucléaire
extrêmement logique
si vous pensez que ça contribue au
problème c'est évident pour le baisser
alors pour ceux d'entre vous qui ne sont
pas familiers je vous rappelle que le
grand panache blanc que vous avez au
dessus des aéroréfrigérants ça n'est que
de la vapeur d'eau et que ça ne
contribue pas aux émissions de gaz à
effet de serre deuxième chose qui vous
intéressera peut-être quand vous montrez
un aéroréfrigérants à
un polonais ou un américain il pense pas
nucléaire et quand ce charbon
il ya une raison très simple à ça c'est
que l'aéro réfrigérant n'est qu'un moyen
de refroidissement pour une centrale
électrique qui commence par faire
bouillir de l'eau
c'est juste ça donc si vous êtes en bord
de rivière
vous ne pouvez pas suffisamment
réchauffer l'eau de la rivière pour
servir de source froide
y a pas assez d'eau dont vous entendez
vapore une partie et c'est la chaleur
latente de l'évaporation qui vous permet
de vous débarrasser de la chaleur dont
vous voulez plus si vous êtes en bord de
mer
même si vous êtes nucléaire vous n'avez
pas d'aero réfrigérant donc si vous
allez voir sur google ou sur courante
tiens restons français la centrale de
penly où la centrale de flamanville va
vous verrez pas trop écrit géant y en a
pas vous avez pas besoin la berre est
une source froide suffisamment puissante
donc pas de héros autres les géants les
allemands ils ont plein de centrales
avec des aéroréfrigérants qui s'appelle
les centrales à charbon
alors parlons du charbon justement voilà
la manière dont on produit l'électricité
aujourd'hui et sur les 30 dernières
années dans le monde
c'est graduée en térawattheures 1
térawattheures 7,1 milliards de
kilowattheures donc c'est la production
électrique en milliards de
kilowattheures depuis 1981 vous voyez qu
aujourd'hui on est à peu près à 23 mille
milliards de kilowattheures de
production électrique dans le monde
pour mémoire la production électrique
mondiale en 1945 c'est facile c'est les
mêmes chiffres
450 térawattheures donc l'électricité
c'est par excellence l'énergie de la
deuxième moitié du 20e siècle par
excellence l'énergie de la deuxième
moitié du 20e siècle
avant ça existait pas et même au cours
de la deuxième moitié du 20e siècle
il ya encore un certain nombre de gens
aujourd'hui ayant 65 ans ou plus qui
sont nés dans des maisons dans
lesquelles n'y avait pas l'électricité
n'avait juste pas l'électricité
avec quoi est-ce qu'on fait
l'électricité aujourd'hui dans le monde
eh bien vous voyez que la première
source de production électrique et de
très loin
c'est le charbon et quand vous faites de
l'électricité avec du charbon c'est
simple vous faites brûler le charbon
pour faire de la chaleur avec cette
chaleur vous créer de la vapeur sous
pression et avec cette vapeur sous
pression vous faites tourner un
alternateur avec une turbine et ainsi
vous générer de l'électricité
le rendement moyen des centrales à
charbon dans le monde c'est 30 %
c'est-à-dire que 70 % de la chaleur
créée sert à chauffer les petits oiseaux
c'est très exactement le même rendement
moyen que celui des centrales nucléaires
dont il n'y a pas de distinguo
particulier dans les centrales entre
nucléaire et charbon le rendement moyen
est à peu près le même deux tiers de la
chaleur sert à chauffer les petits
oiseaux notamment via les aéro
réfrigérantes quand vous êtes en bord de
rivière 25% de la production électrique
sert à pareille fête à partir de gaz
et si vous regardez sur les 15 dernières
années donc vous vous mettez entre 2000
et 2015 et que vous regardez l'un
crémant de production électrique au
charbon et au gaz
vous voulez que ça écrase de très loin
l'un crémant de production fait avec les
énergies renouvelables que vous avez
tout en haut
ce qui s'est vraiment passé sur les 15
dernières années c'est pas du tout
l'essor du pv l'éolien c'est l'essor du
charbon c'est l'essor du charbon la
consommation de charbon dans le monde
sur les 15 dernières années a augmenté
30 x 25 fois plus que la consommation
d'énergie solaire photovoltaïque
donc ce qui s'est vraiment passé dans le
monde sur les 15 dernières années
c'est l'explosion du charbon après la
bonne question est de savoir pourquoi le
journal vous en à tartiner sur le pv
vous a rien dit sur le charbon mais ça
c'est un autre sujet on fait encore
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
pas mal d'électricité avec enfin pas mal
la même quantité en valeur absolue en
ordre de grandeur ville c'est à peu près
pareil en et du fioul le premier mode de
production tout à fait renouvelables
décarbonés dans le monde c'est
l'hydroélectricité cela étant la grande
hydraulique c'est pas un truc totalement
neutre pour l'environnement je vous
rappelle qu'on a déplacé aux trois
gorges six fois où cette fois les gens
qu'on a déplacé hatcher de bil'in a
déplacé un million de personnes
et c'est absolument certain qu'ils
reviendront pas sauf à devenir des
salamandres et la deuxième est le plus
grand lac de barrage dans le monde
il fait 5000 kilomètres carrés c'est à
dire la superficie d'un département
français confortable donc c'est pas
totalement neutre en termes d'impact sur
l'environnement
le deuxième grand mode de production
décarbonée dans le monde c'est le
nucléaire et puis au dessus vous avez
des trucs qui est excitant les
journalistes donc 10 à 250 grammes de
co2 alors j'ai mis piloter parce que
quand vous avez une énergie fatal quand
le vent souffle ou quand le soleil
brille et que vous décidez que le train
doit avancer quand même même quand il a
pas de vent ou pas de soleil
eh bien il faut rajouter une fonction
qui est la fonction de sécurité
d'approvisionnement de pilotage avec du
stockage et quand vous stockez vous avez
besoin de créer des dispositifs de
stockage et pour ça vous avez besoin
d'avoir ou du ciment ou glaciers ou de
l'industrie chimique ou ce que vous
voulez et ça vous rajoute des émissions
de co2 par kilowattheure qui sera
stockée puis restitués voilà donc si
vous êtes en utilisation directe d'un
kilowattheure éolien vous êtes à 10 si
vous êtes en utilisation stockées sur
batterie d'un kilowattheure de solaire
photovoltaïque vous êtes à 200 pour vous
donner les ordres de grandeur revenons à
la consommation d'énergie donc pardon
pour finir là-dessus
une idée qu'il faut absolument se sortir
de la tête c'est que l'électricité ses
propres l'électricité c'est aussi sale
que la manière de la produire
donc avec l'électricité vous déportés le
problème au lieu de production
et si au lieu de production vous avez
une centrales à lignite
je vous assure qu' il vaut mieux
chauffée vaut mieux utiliser du gaz en
utilisation directe chez vous donc voilà
donc c'est vraiment une question
d'appréciation des quantités d ordre de
grandeur et de quantification des choses
donc c'est je reviens à ce que disait
didier tout à l'heure tant qu'on n'a pas
quantifié les choses dans ce genre de
débat n'a rien dit d'accord on est allé
nulle part on sort pas d'un débat sur
l'énergie et des slogans
ça c'est le meilleur moyen d'aller là où
on pense enfin de ne pas aller là où on
veut aller
tant qu'on n'a pas quantifié on n'a
absolument rien
donc voilà maintenant la quantité
d'énergie qu'on utilise en europe donc
ça didier vous l'a déjà montré 40
concentrés dans les bâtiments alors en
fait c est modulable en fonction du pays
la moyenne effectivement et à 40% et ça
peut varier
donc vous voyez que les pays du sud
portugal malte espagne chypre peuvent
avoir un peu moins parce qu'il fait
chaud les pays qui ont des performances
thermiques de leurs bâtiments qui ont
été réfléchis depuis longtemps donc
l'autriche la finlande la suède
bien que situés dans des zones à climat
rude peuvent avoir un peu moins et à
l'autre extrémité du spectre
là où il fait froid et vous êtes foutus
des performances thermiques des
bâtiments et bien vous pouvez avoir plus
c'est plutôt la partie de droite
notez que le panachage de ces pays est
indépendant de leur image écolo que vous
pouvez avoir dans le journal ou pas vous
voyez au danemark
en termes de parts de l'énergie
consommée dans les bâtiments ils sont
raisonnablement élevé alors qu'ils ont
une image écolo l'espagne non ils sont
plus gras dont il n'ya pas il n'y a pas
de lien
d'une manière générale toujours dans cet
esprit ce n'est pas l'objet de ce matin
mais les hollandais sont sauf erreur de
ma part les plus émissifs en émissions
de co2 par personne en europe alors que
vous avez l'image d'épinal légende
amsterdam qui se balade en vélo et qui
sont vachement écolo donc faut regarder
les chiffres
tant qu'on a pas regarder les chiffres
je le dis on n'a rien fait on n'a rien
fait les médias regarde pas les chiffres
parce que les caméras de télévision ça
regarde pas un chiffre au regard d'un
objet donc les médias ne regarde pas les
chiffres
voilà ici
la répartition de l'utilisation de
l'énergie en france
alors pourquoi est-ce que je vous montre
ça parce que la france il ya un gymnase
une part d'entre vous qui a raté le
slogan pays tout nucléaire et donc à
nouveau on s'est amusé à faire un petit
calcul amusant 44 on a regardé comment
se décompose l énergie dite finale donc
c'est celle qui est utilisée par les
secteurs de consommation finale c'est
pas celle qui rentre dans systèmes
énergétiques qu'on appelle énergie
primaire là on a déduit les pertes du
système énergétique et on regarde
l'affectation de l'énergie par quantité
qui consomment l'énergie donc si
l'énergie à les consommer chez vous par
des machines qui servent soit chauffée
soit autre chose c'est résidentiel si
elle est utilisée par des machines qui
sont dans des bureaux c'est tertiaire si
servent à fabriquer des objets ces
industries si elle est utilisée par des
machines qui sont dans les chancelleries
culture et si elle est utilisée par des
machines qui servent à déplacer des
personnes ou des marchandises ces
transports
c'est ça l'idée donc vous avez entendu
que la france était un pays tout
nucléaire et ici j'ai gradué en
milliards de kilowattheures parce que
toute énergie peut se mesurer en
kilowattheures les skis étaient
consommés par secteur en fonction de
l'énergie de provenances l'énergie
primaire de provenance et maintenant je
cercle ceux qui en france vient des
combustibles fossiles
donc tout ça ça vient des combustibles
fossiles en france et donc je vous pose
la question est-ce que vous pensez que
la france est un pays tout nucléaire
ça doit pouvoir se discuter dans le
chauffage le chauffage
vous voyez que une part du chauffage est
effectivement fait avec du nucléaire là
une part d usage hors chauffage effect
du nucléaire enfin le chauffage en
france c'est avant tout avec des
énergies fossiles
donc tout le monde pense chauffage
électrique
quand on pense chauffage en france non
si vous pensez chauffage en france
penser avant tout pétrole et gaz parce
que la réalité c'est celle là c'est
avant tout du pétrole et du gaz
on utilise quatre fois plus de
combustibles fossiles dans le chauffage
en france qu'on utilise l'électricité
quatre fois plus en quantité de
kilowattheures donc notre premier
problème
a fortiori si on veut décarbonés
l'économie s'est pas l'électricité
d'origine nucléaire
c'est le pétrole et au gaz c'est ça
notre premier problème si on veut
décarbonés le chauffage et on n'est pas
une exception en europe puisque vous
voyez qu'en europe si vous regardez la
répartition de la consommation de ces
chaudes des ménages par nrj vous et que
l'électricité ça fait un quart et que le
reste ça fait trois quarts donc il ya un
rapport de 1 à 3 nous il ya un rapport
de 1 à 4 donc en fait on est même un peu
plus vertueux que le reste des pays
européens
si le critère d'appréciation c'est je
veux pas trop d'électricité dans le
chauffage et la thermo sensibilité c'est
à dire le fait que la consommation
d'électricité augmente hiver c'est pour
moitié due aux chauffages et pour moitié
du à tout un tas d'autres trucs vous
éclairer plus souvent il faut qu'on
chauffe les rails pour les givrés enfin
il ya plein d usage qui n'ont rien à
voir avec le chauffage des habitations
qui augmente significativement l'hiver
et qui expliquent la pointe hivernale
que vous constatez je vous épargne et
les graphiques mais que vous constatez
dans tous les pays d'europe
alors ceci allant avec cela voilà
comment se répartissent en france les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre en
l'occurrence de co2 parce qu'il ya peu
de vache
lily rhodes du méthane chez nous les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre fois
dans les logements les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre par mètre carré et par
an
des logements en france ça a été
discriminée par année de construction
parce que didier l'a rappelé tout à
l'heure vous avez eu en france après les
chocs pétroliers des réglementations
thermiques qui se sont installées et
donc plus les bâtiments ont été
construits récemment et plus on a été
dur sur les contraintes qu'on leur
demande et donc moins il consomme
d'énergie
ce que je vous présente ici cela étant
ça n'est pas ce qu'on appelle la
réglementation les émissions issues de
la réglementation thermique c'est donc
ce n'est pas le calcul théorique de ce
que le bâtiment devrait émettre c'est la
réalité constatée sur base d'un sondage
auprès des ménages sur combien ils
utilisent vraiment d'énergie donc on
prend les factures on prend le prix du
kilowatt heure et on regarde ton et ça
fait de kilowattheures c'est ça qui est
ça la base du calcul
il ya un écart qui peut aller du simple
au quintuple entre les deux c'est à dire
que dans des bâtiments alors j'ai pas
fait avec les logements mais avec les
bureaux je connais quelques personnes
que mon métier de m'occuper de ce genre
de truc qui ont fait le calcul effectifs
de regarder à combien de kilowattheures
par mètre carré et par an était le
bâtiment sur le papier au moment où
l'architecte leur a vendu et le
constructeur de leur a construit et
combien ils consomment pour de vrais c
pa si on a fait ça au siège de saint
gobain et bien vous avez des sièges
sociaux où l'écart à 2 1 à 4 1 à 4
d'accord on pas en train de parler de
10% différence 1 à 4 d'où ce qui a été
dit tout à l'heure auquel je souscris
tout à fait faire des tests faut pas se
contenter de la déclaration sur
l'honneur dix ans votre bâtiment et
mettant sans compter que par ailleurs
les émissions du bâtiment sont calculés
pour une température de consigne qu'il
existe nulle part nulle pa quand on vous
dit vous vous chauffez à 19 degrés
chaque oeil aux savoirs chez qui s'il
fait 19 degrés il prêche et grand monde
donc vous voilà donc si on regarde
vraiment ce qui se passe
voilà ce que vous avez vous voyez que
l'essentiel des émissions viennent du
chauffage ecs et eau chaude sanitaire
donc cvo douche faut pas prendre trop et
après vous avez cuisson et
le reste de l'électricité l'énergie de
chauffage
elle n'est pas du tout répartis de
manière homogène même au sein des
bâtiments
donc vous avez ici par type de
construction maisons individuelles et
logements collectifs les consommations
par logement et par an alors la
consommation par logement et par an aux
dépens de la performance intrinsèque les
émissions par mètre carré est de la
taille du logement et vous allez voir
que la taille du logement a également
beaucoup joué dans ce qui s'est passé au
cours des dernières décennies
donc ici vous avez le les emmy part dans
la consommation d'énergie non pas les
émissions et la consommation d'énergie
par type d'énergie
par type de logement et pour chaque type
d'énergie et chaque type de logement
donc là par exemple vous avez les
maisons individuelles chauffés au gaz en
bleu eh bien vous constatez que vous
avez en gros un gros million de maisons
chauffées au gaz qui sont dites
performance et odette à 10000
kilowattheures par mètre carré et par an
oula vous en avez deux millions et demi
qui sont dans la moyenne et vous en avez
un million qui sont énergivores
vous êtes à 25 mi kilowattheures par
mètre carré et par an voilà vous pouvez
répéter ça pour le fioul s'est donc
voyez que le fuel y en a quand même un
paquet et ça évidemment c'est sûr
représentée dans les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre parce que ce qui est la
sae mais pas beaucoup
ce qui hélas il est déjà plus et ce qui
est là et mais encore plus par mètre
carré
et si vous regardez en nombre de
résidences vous voyez que le nombre de
résidences chauffées à l'électricité est
minoritaire donc l'électricité est
minoritaire dans les kilowattheures et
comme ça concerne souvent des logements
récents donc un peu plus performants que
les logements précédent c'est donc ces
mineurs étaient en nombre de logements
et c'est encore plus minoritaire en
quantité d'énergie consommée
alors vous allez me dire on va très bien
on a des logements qui aujourd'hui en
europe font si je rajoute électricité et
émissions directes me phung trahissent
plus quelque chose allez mettons 20% des
émissions tout mouillé il faut diviser
les émissions par trois donc il faut
s'en occuper de cette affaire donc ça
veut dire qu'il faut mettre de l'argent
là-dedans où va l'argent des bâtiments
aujourd'hui vous avez ici le chiffre
d'affaires de la profession du bâtiment
en france
eh ben vous voyez que la moitié de
l'argent qu'on met dans le bâtiment
aujourd'hui ça va dans l'accroissement
du parc c'est à dire dans le neuf
didier vous a dit tout à l'heure la
rotation du parc c'est 1% par an en fait
non ce qui est important par an c'est
l'accroissement du parc la rotation
c'est un pour mille parce que dans ce
qu'on construit tous les ans une petite
fraction remplace des logements
existants l'essentiel c'est de
l'accroissement du parc parce que
croissance démographique et parce que
croissance vous allez voir à près de la
taille unitaire du logement ou plus
exactement du nombre de mètres carrés
par personne donc le parc de logements
existants il est là et continue à vivre
sa vie par ailleurs c'est pas du tout
les mêmes acteurs
ici vous avez des gros donc les bruits
de vinci eiffage vous allez trouver là
vous allez très peu les trouver là sauf
pour les grands ensembles d'un seul
tenant
parce que quand vous vous appelez
bouygues ou vinci et que vous vous dites
moi j'ai mon pavillon où mon appartement
à rénover il y en a pour dix mille euros
ils vous disent ouais enfin vous êtes
gentils nous il faut 3 0 de plus pour ça
commence à nous intéresser donc bouygues
et vinci ou eiffage
ils vont être intéressés par je prends
l'ensemble des hôpitaux de l'ap-hp et
jeu des reds thermiquement ça ça va les
intéresser
votre sam suffit
maison ou appartement ils s'en foutent
complètement ce n'est pas leur sujet
c'est le sujet des artisans du bâtiment
c'est eux qui sont concernés par la
faire et vous avez chez ces gens là un
milliard d'enjeux de formation de
compréhension de ce qui se passe
etc on aurait pu leur parler un autre
jour c'est pas le sujet d'aujourd'hui
ce qui veut dire que si vous regardez le
nombre de logements voilà comment ils
évoluent c'est la courbe bleue et là
dedans vous avez un stock qui se
contracte très très très légèrement vous
voyez la baisse du trait orange va être
très très légèrement parce que le taux
de renouvellement est bien inférieure à
1%
et puis vous avez d'autres logements qui
viennent se rajouter par dessus les
autres logements aujourd'hui si
effectivement ils obéissent à la norme
ce qui est pas toujours le cas c'est pas
le sujet ils sont déjà tellement
performant c'est pas la peine d'en
rajouter
le vrai sujet c'est la partie orange qui
est en dessous alors je vous disais le
la quantité totale de logements a
augmenté et continue d'augmenter et ça
augmente pour deux raisons la première
c'est que la population croît et la
deuxième c'est que vous avez le nombre
de mètres carrés par personne qui
augmente alors ça augmenter pour deux
raisons augmentation du pouvoir d'achat
et diminution de la taille unitaire des
ménages
les deux étant corrélé du reste 1 il
faut que le pouvoir d'achat par personne
augmente pour qu'on puisse divorce est
donc dans le monde qui s'annonce on
divorce en ramant facilement oui quand
divorcera moins facilement
économiquement ça sera plus en plus
difficile voilà donc pour ceux d'entre
vous qui sont concernés conseiller à vos
enfants bien choisir ce sera moins
facile d'aller voir ailleurs
ceci allant avec cela
quand je regarde les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre liées à notre
consommation
voilà un diagramme qu'on a fait chez
carbone 4 et qui est la vision
consommation des émissions comme souvent
on vous dit on voulait dit tout à
l'heure faut baisser les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et alors
et crypto communiste que nous sommes
tous en france la france est quand même
à une espèce de pays communistes ont dit
ah c'est la faute des industriels donc
on va dire à monsieur didier reault
qu'est ce que tu fous et les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre et puis si tu
les baisse pas assez vite je prends une
corde en chambre de bonne qualité et
quick un filet donc en gros le problème
de la baisse des émissions c'est le
problème de ces [ __ ] d'industriels
nous quand même on va quand même pas se
restreindre
alors pour savoir si ce débat est
totalement justifiée on a fait chez
carbone 4 un raisonnement un peu
différent qui est que quand vous achetez
un tapis une paire de lunettes ou
un costume même pas celui de fillon ou
une voiture
personne ne vous met un revolver sur la
tempe
en dix ans achètent personnes d'accord
donc vous pouvez dire j'ai besoin d'une
bagnole pour aller au travail très bien
merci
personne ne vous oblige à vous et à
acheter au maximum de votre budget vous
pouvez acheter au minimum de votre
budget d'accord vous pouvez acheter un
truc qui vous trois fois moins cher qui
sera moins confortable qu'il y aura
moins lite qui sera pluvieux etc vous
pouvez faire d'accord personne vous mais
un revolver sur la tempe en disant tu es
obligé de faire ça et quand vous allez
dans une grande surface personne vous
dit achète la poupée barbie avec un
revolver sur la tempe
c'est un acte vous faites de manière
délibérée pouvez très bien vous ramener
à l'anniversaire du petit dernier avec
pas de poupée barbie 3 chiffon en lui
disant tiens on va jouer à la poupée
avec les trois chiffres deux personnes
d'accord
donc on est parti d'une vision qui est
la vision consommation dit autrement
quand j'achète quelque chose ou que je
profite d'un service que l'état a mis à
ma disposition
combien est-ce que ça engendre
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans
toute la chaîne de production qui a
précédé mon achat pour que cette affaire
là existent et que je puisse en profiter
d'accord donc au moment où j'ai acheté
ces excellentes lunettes parce que je
deviens vieux et bien il a fallu que les
petits copains de notre ami ici présent
la fabrique de l'acier a pas en grande
quantité mais quand même pour fabriquer
ma paire de lunettes que les petits
copains de notre ami ici présents
fabrique du verre pour quelque chose qui
ressemble pour faire les verres de
lunettes que les copines total à il me
faire un trou dans le sol
me sortent du pétrole me fasse du naphta
me fasse du pétrole du plastique pour
faire les branches de lunettes etc etc
j'achète ses lunettes je profite de
toutes ces émissions et je vais les
ranger dans une catégorie ici qui
s'appelle autres biens de consommation
d'accord quand j'achète ma paire de
lunettes
je profite de toutes les émissions
industrielles hamon qui ont permis à la
paire de lunettes d'exister puis si j'ai
pas envie que ce truc là et si je peux
très bien ne pas acheter la paire de
lunettes
je peux je vois moins bien je connais
pas l'acheter donc ici vous avez les
émissions vu sous l'angle de la
consommation finale d'un français en
1990 et en 2010 alors dans ces émissions
je n'ai pas de territorialisation c'est
à dire que je me fous de savoir où les
émissions ont pris place
et en l'occurrence quand j'achète ma
paire de lunettes avec du plastique les
émissions de production du pétrole
une chose est sûr c'est qu'elles n'ont
pas pris place sur le sol français il
n'y a pas de pétrole en france
petit peu dans la forêt de fontainebleau
enfin c'est marginal
donc les émissions de production
l'énergie qu'il a fallu utiliser pour
pomper comme les shadoks là est bien
celle là j'en suis sûre qu'elles ont pas
pris place en france les émissions de
fabrication de l'acier se retrouvent
elles n'ont pas pris place en france etc
et puis des émissions des transports
intermédiaire y en a une partie compris
tu l'as en france dès que vous achetez
un truc made in china va vous achetez
des émissions compris passons en chine
et en pratique vous acheter du made in
charbon donc vous en bénéficiez alors
bénéficier voilà donc les français vont
construire et bien chaque année rapporté
à la population un français émet 400 kg
de co2 pour l'acte de construction
évidemment vous fait pas tous construire
en 400 kg de co2 il faut savoir que
c'est une construction en structure
béton d'un mètre carrés de logements et
400 kg de co2
évidemment vous n'achetez pas je vous
chaque année en mètres carrés de
logements structure béton collectif par
contre l'année où vous faites construire
donc que vous investissez dans un truc
neuf où vous allez habiter dans un truc
9 bat alors à ce moment vous héritez
crack d'un seul coup d'un seul de vos 80
mètres carrés à 400 kg par mètre carré
donc là vous pourrez prendre de tonnes
d'un seul coup mais si je répartis en
moyenne annuelle sur tous les français
c'est 400 kg par personne et par an
ensuite le logement il faut l'entretenir
donc ça vous avez la consommation
d'énergie des logements dans cette
affaire les bureaux je ne les vois pas
parce que les bureaux il participe à
l'acte productif donc les émissions de
fonctionnement des bureaux sont
disséminés chez les émissions des
constructeurs pour leurs sièges sociaux
chez les émissions des gens qui vont me
vendre la nourriture chez les émissions
des gens qui vont fabriquer le restent
chez les émissions du siège social de
renault etc s'est disséminé ailleurs
dans d'autres cadres ensuite je mange
avec ce que je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure vous voyez que manger ces deux
tonnes et demie équivalent co2 par
personne et par an retenaient que dans
cette affaire le cheptel bovin c'est les
deux tiers donc il faut aimer nos
éleveurs mais avec moins de vaches
ça veut dire qu'il faut payer les vaches
plus cher c'est très exactement ça qu'il
faut faire
donc il faut leur demander de produire
deux fois moins de la haute qualité et
payer trois fois plus en première
approximation les autres biens de
consommation donc tout ce qui n'est pas
alimentation donc là dedans vous avez
les canapés etc vous voyez que ça a très
fortement augmenté sur 20 ans les deux
tiers de cette augmentation c'est
l'apparition de ça en 1990 les
téléphones portables les ordinateurs et
les télés à écran plat ça n'existait pas
et bien la fabrication annuelle des
télés ordinateurs et aux smartphones que
nous utilisons aujourd'hui et que nous
remplaçons le plus souvent possible et
bien la fabrication annuelle
ces deux tiers de l'augmentation de ce
truc là c'est une autre manière de dire
qu'aujourd'hui l'émergence des
technologies de l'information ça rien
décarbonés du tout vous voyez pas la
baisse dans les autres bars et vous
voyez la hausse dans cette barre qui aux
deux tiers est due à l'émergence des
technologies de l'information
donc quand on dit les technologies de
l'information ça permet de décarbonés
l'économie je dis ouais peut-être le
résultat que je constate sur les 20
dernières années c'est que ça fait
l'exact inverse les déplacements de
personnes ont un peu augmenté
alors là dedans les émissions dues à la
voiture sont restés stables et il s'agit
bien des déplacements personnels
donc si vous êtes vrp vendeur de
cravates ça compte pas c'est dans les
éditions de fabrication des cravates et
ça tombera chez les particuliers dans
les achats de cravate
par contre si vous vous déplacez pour
aller voir vos enfants partir en
vacances ou aller faire des courses
c'est dans les déplacements de personnes
et l'essentiel de l'augmentation c'est
l'avion parce qu'en 1990 l'avion restait
encore un luxe relatif sa forte
démocratisation est liée notamment à
l'augmentation de la quantité de pétrole
qu'on avait dans le système aérien et
donc aux augmentations et enfin vous
voyez les services alors presque vous
avez des émissions dans les services
marcquois parce que nous avons une armée
dont quelques chars les avions les
porte-avions ça consomme du pétrole
parce que nous avons un système éducatif
et que les enseignants entendent être
chauffée l'hiver et leur classe aussi
pour faire court et c'est donc tout ça
et vous nous avons un hôpital et pour
faire fonctionner l'hôpital il faut le
chauffer faut fabriquer des scalpels et
des irm etc tout ça consomme de
l'énergie
du co2 le total ici vous voyez que c'est
un peu plus de 10 tonnes soit dit en
passant il faut le ramener à 2 tonnes en
35 ans pour tenir la corde paris je ne
sais pas je vous dis sur le chatelier
vous dis que le système finira par se
réguler un jour tout seul ça j'en suis
absolument sûr si j'attends suffisamment
longtemps un jour les émissions sont à 2
tonnes par personne
j'en suis absolument sûr puisque les
combustibles fossiles étaient en
quantité finie tant en quantité donnée
une fois pour toutes la limite à +
l'infini de leur consommation annuelle
c'est zéro donc je sais que il ya un
moment où les émissions par personne
seront redescendu sous de tonnes c'est
une absolue certitude je sais pas vous
dire quand et comment mais c'est une
absolue certitude que ça finira par
arriver et je le redis vaut mieux que ce
soit avec nous son nom dernier point sur
la partie pognon vous avez ici les le
finir par ça les émissions pardon un
graphique qui va vous donner la
rentabilité intrinsèque des gestes
d'isolation ça va donner quelques
boutons à didier même la rentabilité
intrinsèque des gestes d'isolation vous
avez ici en rouge
combien vous coûte par centime
l'électricité et le gaz en france en
ordre de grandeur
alors le gars est très fluctuant c'est
monté jusqu'à 7 c descendu jusqu'à 3 et
demi je voulais vie à cinq pour mettre
tout le monde d'accord
l'électricité aujourd'hui c'est aux
alentours de 15 centimes d'euro du
kilowattheure est ici vous avez la
dépense d'investissement qui est
nécessaire pour économiser un
kilowattheure en fonction du geste que
vous allez faire alors un investissement
à une durée dit donc au moment où vous
investissez vous faites quelque chose
sur le logement qui va vous permettre
d'économiser de l'énergie par exemple
vous isoler les combles ou remplacez les
vitrages et c'est sa durée de vie une
fenêtre ça a une durée de vie même la
laine de verre dans les combles ça a une
durée de vie et vous répartissez les
économies d'énergie sur toute la durée
de vie de ce que vous venez de faire et
vous prenez ce que ça vous coûte
aujourd'hui de faire ce geste donc de
changer une fenêtre ou de mettre de la
laine de verre dans les combles et vous
amortissez ce coût sur les économies sur
la durée de vie du geste que vous venez
de faire application pratique je fais un
geste qui vaut mille euros
ça dure dix ans donc ça fait 100 euros
par an et ça me permet d'économiser 500
kilowatts heure par an à ce moment mon
geste
il vaut 20 centimes d'euros
d'investissements par kilowattheure
économisé une règle de trois camps et je
vais vous détailler ce que vous avez là
donc le premier geste qui manifestement
est rentable ça vaut le coup de le faire
puisque ça va vous coûter moins par
kilowattheure éviter que n'importe
laquelle des énergies que vous pouvez
utiliser c'est l'isolation des combles
perdus
donc vous avez des combles perdus dans
un pavillon des combles perdus s'ils n'y
a pas de grenier dedans y'a pas de
chambre y à rien et vous allez dans
votre pavillon sous le toit
m 20 c'est pas bien 40 didier plus
heureux cm de laine de verre corps avec
un coffrage pour éviter que l'air
circule comme il l'a dit tout à l'heure
eh bien le coût de cette affaire
rapportée à ce que ça va vous permettre
d'économiser c'est rentable donc c'est
un geste que vous avez intérêt à faire
en tant que tel à n'importe quel moment
ensuite vous envoyer un deuxième qui est
toujours rentable si vous êtes quelle
que soit l'énergie à laquelle vous êtes
chauffé qui est l'isolation des planches
et des planchers bas après vous tombez
dans un geste qui n'est pas rentable si
vous êtes chauffé à la plus émissive d2
énergie que j'ai là mais qui est
rentable si vous êtes chauffé à
l'électricité c'est quand même un comble
pardon du jeu de mots que la rentabilité
si on s'intéresse au climat vous oriente
vers le sens que je fais des efforts
s'ils utilisent un truc qui est déjà peu
carbonée alors que si j'utilise un truc
et plus carbonées j'en fais pas qui est
l'isolation thermique par l'intérieur
alors l'isolation thermique par
l'intérieur soit dit en passant pose un
problème comptable redoutable qui et
comment vous comptabilisez la surface
perdue parce que si vous isolez par
l'intérieur ça vous suppriment des
mètres carrés selon que ça vous en
supprime un peu ou beaucoup non mais
c'est un vrai sujet donc si vous faites
des trucs très minces
c'est pas une question si vous faites
des trucs très épais
avec 20 cm de laine de verre et un
coffrage c'est pas négligeable du tout
la surface que vous allez perdre et donc
avec la manière dont aujourd'hui on
compte la valeur vénale des logements
vous avez une perte en patrimoine qui
est réel c'est pas juste une vue de
l'esprit
1 en plus du coût technique donc c'est
un c'est un vrai sujet ensuite vous avez
l'isolation des toitures donc là c'est
pas des combles perdus c'est la toiture
ensuite vous avez l'isolation thermique
par l'extérieur alors tout ça est
rentable si vous êtes chauffé à
l'électricité ça ne l'est déjà plus si
vous êtes au gaz et le truc le moins
rentable en fait c'est les fenêtres
alors c'est le moins rentable et c'est
quand même là où les gens à mettre
l'essentiel de l'argent pourquoi parce
qu'en fait vous avez une âme est dit est
très forte
quand vous changez les fenêtres qui est
le bruit est en fait l'essentiel des
gens vont le faire avant tout pour ça et
pas avant tout pour la performance
thermique
ici je vous ai donné là la règle du jeu
du coup vous n'avez que deux manières de
faire en sorte que l'économie vous
pousse vers l'isola se faire vers la
l'augmentation de performance thermique
c'est ou bien à vous monter le prix de
l'énergie c'est le principe de la taxe
carbone ok je suis favorable
ou bien vous descendez le coût unitaire
une autre manière de pénaliser les
logements mal isolés c'est de les
pénaliser autrement qu'à travers leur
consommation énergétique par exemple de
manière fiscal on pouvait dire si j'ai
un truc est fortement énergivores je
vais pas être macro n'est ce que je vais
être inversement mac rodez j'augmente la
taxe d'habitation ou j'augmente pour
être plus équitable plus exactement non
pas la taxe d'habitation et les impôts
fonciers comme ça c'est de propriétaires
que je touche à la que je que je marque
pas aujourd'hui soit dit en passant on a
une réglementation dite thermique qui
est orienté énergie et qui n'est pas
l'orienter co2 en venir c'est pareil je
veux dire non parce que justement les
énergies en france sont très discriminés
en fonction de leur contenu en co2
l'électricité les très peu le gaz et le
fioul de sont beaucoup plus je serai en
pologne 1 effectivement ça serait
pertinent de dire je vais tout collé en
énergie primaire et je m'occupe pas du
reste je vais m'occuper que de l'énergie
parce que effectivement comme en pologne
80% d'électricité voire plus et faites
au charbon de moins consommer d'énergie
dans le bâtiment que ce soit moins
d'électricité ou moins de fioul dans
tous les cas de figure c'est une bonne
affaire
en france ça serait intelligent d'être
plus discriminée que ça or il se trouve
que la réglementation thermique en
france a été fortement poussé désolé de
dire des choses désagréables par une
alliance objective des antinucléaires et
des gaziers et donc est la gréve et
l'électricité d'un coefficient 2 58
entre le moment où vous regardez la
facture du consommateur final et le
moment où vous faites la comptabilité
dit autrement vous prenez la facture du
consommateur final et vous la x 2,58
pour obtenir la quantité que vous prenez
en compte dans la réglementation
thermique et ce facteur de 58 est
supposé correspondre au dégagement de
chaleur que vous avez dans le coeur de
la centrale
versus d'électricité qui finit par en
sortir alors je le redis si vos
centrales sont au charbon c'est pas con
c'est très bien de faire ça si vos
centrales sont nucléaire comme vous
n'allez pas casser des noyaux d'uranium
chez vous c'est un raisonnement qui n'a
pas beaucoup d'intérêt et ici vous avez
un croisement qui a été fait entre les
entre l'étiquette énergie et l'étiquette
gaz à effet de serre pour un certain
nombre de logements alors vous voyez
certes que si vous êtes très mauvais en
énergie chains art que vous soyez assez
mauvais en effet de serre que vous soyez
dans les dents le haut mais si vous êtes
intermédiaires et bien vous pouvez être
pas mal en énergie et très mauvais en
effet de serre ou au contraire un peu
plus mauvais en énergie est très bon en
effet de serre d'accord vous voyez que
là vous avez une espèce de ventre mou ou
si vous êtes très bon en énergie vous
serez très bon en effet de serre aussi
mais vous avez une espèce de ventre mou
dans lequel en gros vous pouvez si vous
obliger à rénover thermiquement en
allant de là vers là et bien vous pouvez
très bien à cette occasion passé de là à
là et pour ne pas les nommer aujourd'hui
la caisse des dépôts finances
explicitement du passage de
l'électricité au gaz dans le logement
social à cause de ça à cause de fête que
vous gagnez deux classes de diagnostic
de performance énergétique à cause du
2,58 qui a été amené par les
antinucléaires et les gaziers au moment
du grand
probablement qu'on peut discuter de la
pertinence du système
probablement pour finir puisque j'ai
épuisé mon heure si on a 30 millions de
logements en france et qu'on veut avoir
raisonnablement décarbonés en 35 ans
vous avez lors de grandeur comme moi
font faire un million par an 1 million
par an c'est évident que vous ne le
ferez pas ni avec la force de travail
actuellement dans le bâtiment ni avec
les facilités financières qui sont
aujourd'hui mises à disposition des
ménages
ça doit devenir beaucoup plus simple
laissant les villes le truc évident
c'est d'embarquer la performance
thermique au moment où vous faites des
travaux de toute façon donc si de toute
façon vous devez faire un ravalement
externe
c'est idiot à ce stade de ne pas
rajouter de l'isolation par l'extérieur
et me fait pas le coût du bâtiment
haussmannien dont je vous ai parlé au
début je vous rappelle que dans
énormément de logements qui ont été
construits après guerre et qui ressemble
comme je voulais montrer à ça c'est pas
vraiment le sujet de à caractéristiques
architecturales et la caractéristiques
architecturales de ce truc là je pense
pas que ce soit un sujet majeur
et même là caractéristiques
architecturales de ce truc là c'est pas
un essai pas un sujet majeur non plus et
celle là non plus donc tout ça ça
s'isole par l'extérieur à l'occasion des
ravalements très très simplement
pareil si vous devez changer la toiture
de toute façon c'est pertinent à ce
moment là de faire le geste de
l'isolation le faire en tant que tel
c'est pas rentable de faire à ce
moment-là c'est voilà donc ça c'est
toutes les mesures qui permettent de
baisser le coût du geste technique parce
que vous mutualisé avec autre chose que
vous allez faire de toute façon
voilà je quelques éléments de réflexion
dont je vous le redis un million de
logements par an à rénover c'est ça
l'objectif qu'il faut avoir en tête et
on ne le fera pas à moyens constants
c'est absolument évident voilà didier
avait dit vous a fait une promesse
électorale il a dit qu'avec tant pour
les questions
hahaha